during last night's 11 inning World
Series game 11 innings a Dodgers fan got
arrested after he jumped into one of the
bullpens yeah yeah afterwards the
Dodgers admitted if the game had gone
one more inning they would have needed
him to pitch because they had no one
what else is going on
applause went on a little too long that
was sarcasm over there
was he that good good for you go him I
became Trump like therefore second
speaking of Trump today President Trump
had the JFK files Declassified yeah yeah
Trump said I can take the class out of
anything what's going on Woody Allen has
a new movie have you heard about it I
have yeah Woody Allen's
newest movie features a middle-aged man
who is sleeping with a 15 year old girl
yeah yeah the movie will premiere it can
in May and be entered into evidence in
June so Halloween coming up be getting
ready for that it's like a children's
show and have ghosts and goblins yeah
[Laughter]
Halloween coming up yeah okay a fast
food restaurant in Australia it's a true
story is celebrating Halloween by
offering a hamburger in a blue bun
sprinkled with real ants and worms yeah
yeah or as Arby's calls that the number
six
then a flag these people bring a flag
here which flag to have is that Mexico I
can't my lighting isn't good is it
Mexico it's a Mexican blanket let's can
flag ah come on star we beyond okay yes
there is no wall at this show okay
that should be a new thing everyone
should bring the flag to this show where
they're from this would be a new toy
you're not showing proper respect for
your own flag you are holding it while
you were applauding and then you started
to use it to warm yourself in the cold
audience
you